if you use double angle here's a
solution you come up with okay and we
generated all these values out and I
actually recommend particularly for this
question I'm trying to illustrate
something here right that you draw your
table of values and going up to N equals
3 is plenty okay that's you know that's
12 values that's a lot of work actually
to evaluate all of those but then the
solution that the texts were provided
it's actually blue fits i think from
memory is this solution okay now I told
you and you kind of took it for granted
that these two were equivalent cuz i
said so but that's that's the proof okay
you can see well it's that sort of harm
count through it hmm Princeton cr0 here
check high on to where does that come up
down here actually comes up in a
different column as what you might
expect right so it lines up with this
step solutions pi is here 3 pi/2 comes
up over here and I think you're going
you sort of get the idea right you can
see the pattern is sufficient but all of
the solutions are getting it covered so
my question to you wise well if these
two solutions are valid how did they
even arrived at this other solution like
what else could you really do with this
thing okay now i'm going to show you the
way that they get it and even though in
this question either of these really are
fine okay it wouldn't matter which
method you chose which identities you
chose I'll later on there will be
questions where you need to use this
second method okay because the first
method would be sufficient and i'll show
you the exact question that i'm
referring to in 22 e once we're done
okay so to have a look at this thing
actually before we look at how to solve
this let me draw your attention back to
this now i sent the clues i hear all
about that three okay that that sort of
gives you a hint as to what identities
you're going to need to use now
recovered me is the only the third
lesson that we've known our general
solution Forge ok so for 10 cars and
okay what are the general solutions
remember let's start with the easiest
one at the front of ten it's M PI right
plus relating a go either call it theta
you don't say pilot eats or other angles
I'm 3.3 what we could just call it an
inverse of whatever is a perfectly on
the other side I'm just going to call
the theater for now because i think you
know is talking about my new okay cuz
I'm yeah good the period is done right
but also we have to go back and forth
you have to go to the left and to the
right to get rid of solutions that you
wanted okay the last they sign the we
don't want okay has this switch in the
middle it's really really smart
sometimes it goes left sometimes it goes
right depending on whether it's ordering
night okay now these are these are it
these are all of the forms for general
solution okay so if you have the general
solution for something you know we have
a look at these it has the car from one
of these three there are no other
options okay they might be feeling
around a little bit there might be
different related angles but essentially
the basic idea has to come from one of
these now when you look at this which
form doesn't match up to there's only
one which has a plus minus inner right
Emily cosine ok so we're we're sort of
ditching this and this as the means by
which they arrived at this solution but
there's an on three here right know if
this is not three there that means at
some stage during their solution they
must have divided everything through by
three okay including this angle on the
end right so what that implies if this
is our solution here is that where they
got it from is that this three used to
be over here right we saw that when we
are we brought this down to 2 x's you
got to x equals blah blah blah blah blah
you get your general solutions and then
you have to divide by 2 to get X okay
well clear they've done the CB here but
with three okay so this equation mustn't
actually look like this to the new grid
okay now the question is why is there a
3x then or how is there are three X
there we can you get a 3x out of this
well you can sort of to see
right up in there right if we wanted to
shove a 3x in there you could do this
okay I like well is that a helpful way
to do it when you expand that out right
I'm just going to leave this sine 2x for
a second you're going to get signed this
is just our regular old sign extension
sign a caused B plus cos a sign bit okay
so far so good now you might think ok
well what am I gonna have to do to this
sine 2x in order to get it to interact
with this well the normal way that you
would break down side to access with
dell lang right so you have to sign x
cos x but that's a problem okay because
then you've got if i had a minus 2 sine
x cos x over here okay even though that
seems a little simpler than this at
least everything's in terms of X is
amount of x is over here at this point
you're stuck you really can't do very
much okay there's nothing there's no
time factor Isis which all three of them
so i cant factorize properly in order to
get a solution so this is not a useful
way to go so what do you do will you
remember that in the end i'm going to
get 3 x's right all the way through so
there is actually a 3x hiding in there
in a very similar way that is Heidi here
right because i can write 2x as 3x minus
x ok do you like really that seems like
it's going to make i have two times
before and now in a second i'm going to
get four right which we are let's write
it down i'm going to get minus and just
be careful we did Rafferty 3 x.x
so this looks drastically worse right
I've doubled the number of terms that
I've got at the terms that I've got look
a lot less but it's not that bad right
what happens here yeah that's right
because these two are conjugates of each
other right and the way these identities
work is a lot of symmetry to it okay so
this term here and this token you will
cancel okay leaving me with this and a
double negative so I'm going to get this
and that's where the 3x comes from can
you see it now by the way because I've
got zero on the right hand side actually
don't need to worry about that too it's
just going to be this close three X sine
X is equal to zero so you break apart
and I think you guys could probably take
over yeah right and in fact even from
that line you may be able to see exactly
where these two come out ok now like I
said for this particular question you
really could have gone either way ok you
could have gone I don't think either
solution looks prettier than the other
it's not like 41 you get just one
solution in this one you got to so
they're equal but if you have a look at
your booklet same exercise this is
question 30 what was it 30 to something
like that yeah this is 32 if you have a
look at a question later on question 49
49 which starts off very similar but can
you see the subtle difference in
question 49 means that you really have
to go this way right if you go the
double angle broom ok you break that
sign for X apart into two and so the
left-hand side will be nice but your
right hand side was to be a problem you
can't break up that 3x nicely you're
going to end up with things that are
still different signs so you need to
have this break up because it removes
all the terms really nicely and England
ok so all this to say remember all of
your identity to go about it is right t
method auxiliary angle general solution
even though we've treated them
separately
they really quite continues with all the
stuff we looked at on three expansions
trigger than these three equations and
you need to have it all in your head at
the same time and even a question like
say which one was it we're looking at
just now
question 30 for instance close x minus
sine x equals 1 now when you have a look
at that what are we going to use what's
probably the best way to approach that
question using our prior knowledge
before we get to the general solution
probably auxiliary angle right you could
do it buddy results but because it's in
or what it's a difference of wave
functions right clothes and sign and
it's an easy one as well one where the
coefficients are really easy to deal
with you might as well put it into a
tiller Iain go and then go ahead and
solve it right your is solution like
this ok any questions yeah yeah so
instead of your right so you can see
that these values of N or M or whatever
right they will give you a different set
of solutions for instance you know these
first four here you've got to go I only
get them in the first three here right
so N equals 2 for these sets of
illusions would correspond to N equals 3
for this solution so what they'll tend
to do is run insane give us the
solutions up to N equals whatever is
they'll ask for the first 3 4 5 and not
in the first k number of solutions right
because that's going to be unambiguous
depending on which more we've got don't
mean 0 and plan 6 then piled soon then
get the ID ok or they'll give you a
domain go so give us not a supine or
give us 2 pi 2 45 or give us minus
client 2 pi in that case the form that
you have is immaterial you can use
either one that will still get the same
solution ok good question